This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. One morning in March each year, I raised the window shades in my home and see that the cherry tree outside has exploded into blue. The tree has bear branches one day, a riot of delicate white flowers the next. The last time this happened, the change was so spectacular that I reached for my phone to capture the moment. But the photo failed to show what my eyes had seen. For one thing, the camera included lots of details my brain ignored, stray branches,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。每年三月的某天早晨，我拉起家里的百叶窗，看到外面的樱桃树在一夜之间繁花怒放。树枝前一天还光秃秃的，第二天就开满了精致的白花。上一次看到这情景时，变化是如此壮观，我忍不住拿手机去捕捉这一刻。但照片却没能展现出我双眼所见之物。首先，相机拍下了很多被我大脑忽略的细节，比如零星的树枝，
the edge of my windowsill. The light in the picture was not as brilliant as it had appeared to me just moments earlier. More importantly, the image didn't capture the meaning my brain perceived when I saw the tree in bloom. The message that winter was nearly over, that spring was around the corner. Let me now ask you a question. Which version of the cherry tree represents reality better? The one in the photo? Or the one inside my head? Today we launch a two-part series
窗台的边缘。照片中的光线远没有几分钟前呈现在我眼中的那样灿烂。更重要的是，当我看到樱桃树盛开时，这张照片没能捕捉到我大脑所感知的含义。那就是冬天即将过去，春天就在眼前的信息。现在让我问你一个问题。樱桃树的哪个版本更能代表现实？照片里的那个？还是我脑海中的那个？今天，我们推出一个分两部分的系列节目，
that explores what happens when two ways of understanding come into conflict with each other. One is objective, the other is subjective, one aims for precision, the other is attentive to meaning. Each can be bewildered, even suspicious of the other. Two ways of seeing this week on Hidden Brain. Richard Davidson grew up in Brooklyn during the 1960s. When he was in high school, he came across an article in the magazine Science News about a study. I had read about a sleep laboratory that was based in a hospital in Brooklyn, my monody's
探讨当两种理解方式发生冲突时会发生什么。一种是客观的，另一种是主观的；一种追求精确，另一种关注意义。这两种方式可能会对彼此感到迷惑，甚至怀疑。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨这两种观察视角。理查德·戴维森（Richard Davidson）20世纪60年代在布鲁克林长大。上高中时，他在《科学新闻》杂志上偶然读到一篇关于一项研究的文章。我曾读过关于一家睡眠实验室的报道，它设在布鲁克林的一家医院里，也就是我母亲的
hospital, actually the hospital that I was born in a hospital in Brooklyn, my monody's hospital, actually the hospital that I was born in. Richie called the hospital to ask if he might be able to volunteer in the lab. You know, I talked to some receptionist who kind of dismissed me and it took more persistence. I actually wrote a letter, a handwritten letter, and then followed it up with another phone call. And although they had never had a high school volunteer before, we were able to work out
医院，实际上就是我出生的那家医院，布鲁克林的一家医院，我母亲的医院，实际上就是我出生的那家医院。理奇（Richie）打电话给医院，询问自己是否能在实验室里做志愿者。你知道的，我和某个前台接待人员交谈过，他有点打发了我，这需要更多的毅力。我实际上写了一封信，一封手写的信，然后又打了一通电话跟进。尽管他们以前从未招收过高中生志愿者，但我们还是商定出了一种
an arrangement. In the afternoons after school, while other kids were playing sports or doing homework, Richie would take the subway to the hospital. He got to help around the lab, doing basic work, likeie would take the subway to the hospital. He got to help around the lab doing basic work like cleaning electrodes. But one time he got permission from his parents to stay up all night and watch the scientists in action. The research subject was sleeping in another room that was adjacent to the room that I was in. It had a bed and they were wired up so they were recorded for brain electrical activity measurement. Also electrodes were on
安排。放学后的下午，当其他孩子在进行体育活动或做作业时，理奇会坐地铁去医院。他开始在实验室里帮忙做一些基础工作，比如，理奇会坐地铁去医院。他开始在实验室里帮忙做一些基础工作，比如清理电极。但有一次，他获得了父母的许可，得以熬夜通宵观察科学家们的工作。研究对象睡在另一个房间里，那个房间就挨着我所在的房间。里面有一张床，他们身上连着电线，以便记录他们的脑电活动测量数据。此外，他们的
their eyes to record eye movements. And so I saw the electrodes being put on and I saw this person going to sleep. The scientists would let the person drift into dreams, the REM cycle. And then a person was awakened and asked, was there anything going through your mind? Just before we awakened you? And you know, one of the interesting things is that although most people don't remember their dreams when you wake a person up immediately after a Rem period like this, typically you do get recall in the vast majority of cases. What was amazing to Richie was that scientists could learn about the dream in two completely different ways.
眼睛上也贴了电极，用来记录眼球运动。于是，我看到电极被贴上去，也看到这个人入睡。科学家们会让这个人进入梦境，即快速眼动（REM）睡眠周期。然后，把这个人唤醒并问他：在你被我们叫醒之前，脑子里有什么想法吗？你知道，其中一个有趣的事实是，尽管大多数人在醒来后都不记得自己的梦，但如果你在像这样的一段快速眼动期结束后立即叫醒一个人，通常在绝大多数情况下，你确实能唤醒他的回忆。让理奇感到惊奇的是，科学家们可以通过两种完全不同的方式来了解这个梦。
They could objectively measure the dreamer's eye movements and capture patterns of brain activity. But they could also match this objective data with the dreamer's subjective account of the dream. You know, I was just more taken with the whole process that here is a strategy for looking at the physiological correlates of mental experience. And this was a way to study this. It was a whole kind of paradigm that was unfolding before me that I had never thought about before, and it was super exciting to me. It was exciting for Ritchie at age 14, and it was revolutionary for the time. For centuries, the main way to understand someone's thoughts was to simply ask them.
他们可以客观地测量做梦者的眼球运动，并捕捉脑电活动模式。但他们也可以将这些客观数据与做梦者对梦境的主观描述进行匹配。你知道，我只是对整个过程更加着迷：这里竟然有一种策略，可以用来观察心理体验的生理相关机制。这是一种研究它的方法。整个范式就在我眼前展开，这是我以前从未想过的事情，它让我感到超级兴奋。这对14岁的理奇来说很兴奋，在当时也具有革命性意义。几个世纪以来，了解一个人想法的主要方法就是直接去问他们。
The person would describe what was happening inside their head. But we humans are prone to bias and blind spots, forgetfulness and vanity. Everyone from scientists to marketers to political consultants know, if you really want to learn people's preferences, you should observe how they behave rather than listen to what they say. Where the brain measurement technologies Richie saw at the lab came a new way to study the mind objectively from the outside in. Here was a situation where there was simultaneously a distinct change in the brain that was accompanied by a report of a conscious experience, a mental
这个人会描述他们脑海中正在发生的事情。但我们人类很容易产生偏见、盲区、健忘和虚荣。从科学家到营销人员，再到政治顾问，每个人都知道：如果你真的想了解人们的偏好，你应该观察他们的行为，而不是听他们说的话。理奇在实验室里看到的脑测量技术，带来了一种从外到内客观研究思维的新方法。这里的情况是，大脑中同时发生了一个明显的变化，并伴随着对意识体验、心理
experience. And that, to me, was just mind blowing and captured my imagination. And really, at age 14, as corny it is to say, I knew that my life was somehow going to be dedicated to the study of the mind. I did not know what specific path I would take, but I knew that the mind was really essential to everything that we do, and that that was really the most important thing that I can dedicate myself to. In time, Richie was to become a student of two techniques to understand the mind. One technique tried to understand the mind from the inside out.
体验的报告。这对我来说简直太震撼了，彻底激发了我的想象力。说真的，在14岁时，尽管听起来有些老套，但我知道我的生命某种程度上将致力于对思维的研究。我当时并不知道自己会走哪条具体路径，但我知道思维对我们所做的一切都至关重要，这是我能全身心投入的最重要的事情。随着时间的推移，理奇成为了解思维的两种技术的学生。一种技术试图从内到外地理解思维。
It paid attention to the variety and complexity of mental experiences by turning the spotlight of attention inward. This approach would say that my subjective appraisal of the cherry tree represented reality more accurately. The other technique said the mind could best be understood by studying it from the outside using scientific tools and the scientific method. The goal was to eliminate subjective appraisal as much as possible, because, especially when it came to looking inward, self-perception was flawed and flaky. When we think about our own minds, it's like standing in a hall of mirrors. We cannot tell where reality ends and reflection begins. Ritchie found himself irresistibly drawn to both techniques. He felt each had much to teach the other.
它通过将注意力的聚光灯转向内部，来关注心理体验的多样性和复杂性。这种方法会认为，我对樱桃树的主观评估更准确地代表了现实。另一种技术则认为，最好通过使用科学工具和科学方法从外部对思维进行研究，来理解思维。其目标是尽可能消除主观评估，因为特别是在内省时，自我感知是有缺陷且不稳定的。当我们思考自己的思维时，就像站在镜厅里一样。我们分不清哪里是现实，哪里是倒影。理奇发现自己不可抗拒地被这两种技术所吸引。他觉得每种技术都有很多东西可以教给对方。
He was soon to learn the many ways that practitioners of each technique would be deeply wary of the other. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When I was a teenager, I remember discussing a famous thought experiment with friends. A philosopher in China went to sleep and dreamed he was a butterfly. He flooded from flower to flower, thinking butterfly thoughts and taking butterfly-sized sips of nectar. Then he woke up and realized he wasn't a butterfly, but a man who had dreamed he was a butterfly. The next moment a disturbing thought occurred to him. He had really felt he was a butterfly in the dream. He was convinced he was a butterfly.
他很快就会了解到，这两种技术的践行者对彼此充满深深的戒备。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我年轻时，记得曾和朋友们讨论过一个著名的思想实验。中国的一位哲学家入睡了，梦见自己变成了一只蝴蝶。他在花丛中飞来飞去，思考着蝴蝶的想法，品尝着蝴蝶般大小的花蜜。然后他醒了过来，意识到自己不是蝴蝶，而是一个梦见自己变成蝴蝶的人。接下来的那一刻，一个令人不安的想法浮现在他脑海中：他在梦里真切地觉得自己是一只蝴蝶。他确信自己是一只蝴蝶。
Now, having woken up, he was absolutely convinced he was not a butterfly, but a man. If a man could dream that he was a butterfly, was it not possible that he was now a butterfly dreaming that he was a man? The thought experiment reveals a deep truth. What we perceive as reality cannot be extricated from the workings of our own mind. The world that we experience is actually constructed by our minds and our brains. And so, yeah, there are things out there, but the way we perceive those things that are out there is entirely a function of how we constructed in our own individual minds and brains.
现在醒来后，他绝对确信自己不是蝴蝶，而是一个人。如果一个人能梦见自己是一只蝴蝶，那么他现在会不会是一只正在做梦变成人的蝴蝶呢？这个思想实验揭示了一个深刻的真理。我们所感知的现实无法与我们自身大脑的运作割裂开来。我们体验到的世界实际上是由我们的思维和大脑构建的。所以，是的，外面确实有各种事物，但我们感知那些外界事物的方式，完全取决于我们如何在各自独立的思维和大脑中构建它们。
And so if we can construct it differently, we can literally live in a different world. As Ritchie Davidson came of age, he became very interested in how his mind constructed reality. The counterculture movement of the 1960s was in full swing. Musicians like Jim Morrison were exploring how you could pierce the veil of the 60s and the culture was very much an important influence on my life. It was sort of in the air. I was quite taken with the Beatles and other musical groups who were experimenting with their minds
因此，如果我们能以不同的方式构建它，我们就真的可以生活在另一个世界里。随着理奇·戴维森逐渐长大，他对自己的大脑如何构建现实产生了浓厚的兴趣。20世纪60年代的反主流文化运动正如火如荼地进行。像吉姆·莫里森（Jim Morrison）这样的音乐家正在探索如何穿透60年代的面纱，这种文化对我的生活产生了非常重要的影响。它仿佛弥漫在空气中。我深深地迷上了披头士乐队和其他正在用思维进行实验的音乐家，
and considering the possibility that the kind of standard way that many of us were raised and taught to approach the world to paraphrase Shakespeare, there are more things in heaven that are dreamt of in your philosophy. Bands like the Beatles invited listeners to test the limits of their own minds. When they sang Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds, this was widely perceived to be a reference to the hallucinogenic drug, LSD. I did hear the Beatles live. Lucy in the sky with diamonds was certainly an
并开始思考这样一种可能性：我们许多人被养育和教导对待世界的那种标准方式——用莎士比亚的话来 paraphrase（意译）——在你的哲学中，天地间存在着更多未曾梦想到的事物。像披头士这样的乐队邀请听众去考验他们自己思维的极限。当他们唱起《露西在钻石的天空》（Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds）时，这被普遍认为是在指代致幻剂LSD。我确实听过披头士的现场演出。对我成长影响而言，《露西在钻石的天空》无疑是一首
important song for me growing up. The Harvard Psychologist Timothy Leary was experimenting with magic mushrooms and encouraging volunteers and studies to explore psychedelic drugs. In 1967 he spoke to a group of 30,000 hippies at San Francisco's Golden Gate Park. He urged them to turn on, tune in, and drop out. Drop out. In 1968, the Beatles went to India
重要的歌。哈佛大学心理学家蒂莫西·莱里（Timothy Leary）当时正在用神奇蘑菇做实验，并鼓励志愿者和研究对象探索迷幻药。1967年，他对旧金山金门公园的3万名嬉皮士发表了讲话。他敦促他们：开启（turn on）、调谐（tune in）、脱离（drop out）。脱离。1968年，披头士前往印度，
to learn from a meditation master named Maharishi Maheshiyogi. Gitaras George Harrison in particular developed a deep interest in what was known at the time as transcendental meditation. Richi was fascinated by these ideas, but increasingly he found himself drawn to a related concept. What happens inside our minds doesn't stay inside our minds. The thoughts we think, the feelings we have, can shape and influence the world in which we live. There was a link between our minds and the broken state of the world.
向一位名叫玛哈礼希·玛赫西·优吉（Maharishi Mahesh Yogi）的冥想大师学习。吉他手乔治·哈里森（George Harrison）尤其对当时被称为超觉冥想的东西产生了浓厚的兴趣。理奇对这些想法着迷，但他发现自己越来越被一个相关概念所吸引：我们内心发生的事情不会仅仅留在内心。我们思考的想法、拥有的感受，能够塑造和影响我们所生活的世界。我们的思维与这个破碎的世界状态之间存在着某种联系。
Some of John Lennon's songs specifically, Imagine was really an important song in that whole album. The idea that there is a different way of being that is accessible to all humans. And I would say a way of being that is imbued with greater peace and compassion and kindness and love. You know, in many ways those are still the relevant themes today. and was the impulse here a curiosity about the mind? Or was it an impulse that was shaped more by wanting to see a different kind of world? In other words, when I think about Lucy and the sky with diamonds and I think about Imagine, I actually have a very different
约翰·列农的一些歌曲，特别是《想象》（Imagine），在那张专辑中确实是一首非常重要的歌。这种想法是：所有人类都可以触及一种不同的生存方式。我想说的是，这种生存方式充满了更多的和平、同情、善良和爱。你知道，在许多方面，这些主题在今天依然具有现实意义。这里的冲动是对思维的好奇心？还是由想要看到一个不同世界的愿望所塑造成的冲动？换句话说，当我想到《露西在钻石的天空》和《想象》时，我对这两首歌其实有着非常不同的
impression of those two songs. One is very much about the things that you can do with your mind and, you know, exploring your minds and the way in which your mind can do amazing things. And the other one is very much about you know how it changed my can actually influence and speak and act in the world. So which was it for you? That's a beautiful insight and I would say it was really both. I was very involved in the peace movement, the anti-Vietnam War demonstrations, and very committed social activists. And at the same time, recognizing that our minds have such an important relation to the world in which we live. And so I think we really need both. The year after Imagine came out, Richie started graduate school in psychology at Harvard.
印象。一首非常关于你可以用你的思维做的事情，你知道，探索你的思维以及你的思维能够做出惊人事情的方式；而另一首非常关于你知道它如何改变我的大脑，如何真正影响、发声并在这个世界行动。所以，对你来说，到底是哪一个呢？这是一个美丽的见解，我想说，实际上两者兼有。我非常投入于和平运动、反越战游行，并且是一个坚定的社会活动家。与此同时，我也认识到我们的思维与我们生活的世界有着如此重要的联系。所以我觉得我们两者都需要。《想象》发行后的第二年，理奇进入哈佛大学攻读心理学研究生。
It was 1972. And this was just a little bit after a very controversial psychologist by the name of Richard Albert was fired from Harvard for giving psychedelic drugs to Harvard undergraduates. And of course, he then went off to India and became known as Ramdas. And when I started my graduate work at Harvard, one of the people that I knew was a fellow graduate student. I did not know him at the time. I read a few papers that he published as a graduate student, I did not know him at the time.
那是1972年。这刚好发生在一位备受争议的心理学家理查德·阿尔伯特（Richard Albert）被哈佛开除后不久，原因是他向哈佛的本科生分发迷幻药。当然，他随后去了印度，并被称为拉姆·达斯（Ramdas）。当我开始在哈佛攻读研究生时，我认识的人里有一个也是研究生。我当时并不认识他，我读过他作为研究生发表的一些论文，我当时并不认识他。
I read a few papers that he published as a graduate student. His name was Daniel Goldman. I had never seen a picture of Dan, but I knew he had published these crazy papers on meditation. And in my very first class as a Harvard graduate student, I sit down and this guy sits next to me and I turn to him and I say, you must be Dan Goldman.
我读过他作为研究生发表的一些论文。他的名字叫丹尼尔·戈尔曼（Daniel Goldman）。我从未看过丹的照片，但我知道他发表过这些关于冥想的疯狂论文。在作为哈佛研究生的第一堂课上，我坐了下来，这家伙坐在我旁边，我转过身对他说：你一定是丹·戈尔曼。
And this is not a reflection of any kind of psychic power that I may have. It's simply because he looked like he just came back from India. Anybody would have been able to spot him from a mile away. He was wearing these Indian pants and an Indian shirt and he had beads and his hair was you know wild. He looked different than any of the other students in this class. So indeed he was Dan Goldman and that began our friendship and that night he asked me if I wanted to come over to his house. We had just started talking and it was clear we had so much to share. So I of course accepted his kind invitation and he had a VW micro bus that was plastered
这并不是我拥有什么超能力的表现。这纯粹是因为他看起来像是刚从印度回来。任何人都能在数里之外认出他。他穿着印度的裤子和衬衫，戴着珠子，头发蓬乱。他看起来和这个班上的任何其他学生都不同。所以他确实是丹·戈尔曼，我们的友谊就这样开始了。那天晚上，他问我愿不愿意去他家。我们刚刚开始交谈，很显然我们有那么多共同话题可以分享。所以我当然接受了他亲切的邀请，他有一辆大众微型面包车，
from Florida ceiling with pictures of these yogis. And he drove me to his house and I get there and this guy opens the door and it was Ramdas. What was that first evening like when you and Dan went home and visited with Ramdas, what did you talk about? Did you practice meditation that evening? What did you do? Yeah, we did some practice and you know, it was a kind of deep sharing and I had never met anybody like that before, yet I yearned for it.
从地板到天花板都贴满了这些瑜伽士的照片。他开车带我去了他家，我一到那里，有个家伙开门，竟然是拉姆·达斯。你和丹回家去拜访拉姆·达斯的那第一个夜晚是怎样的？你们聊了什么？那天晚上你们练习冥想了吗？你们做了什么？是的，我们做了一些练习，你知道，那是一种深度的分享。我以前从未见过这样的人，但我却如此渴望它。
And it just completely blew my mind. I had seen pictures of Rondas because Rondas, by then, was famous and his pictures were in the media, and he sort of became my informal teacher and provided an alternative education to my formal Harvard graduate education. He ran this group that met once a week in this house that Dan was living in. And so these were some of the really early influences that were so important in shaping my career.
这简直彻底震撼了我的大脑。我以前看过拉姆·达斯的照片，因为拉姆·达斯到那时已经很有名了，他的照片经常出现在媒体上，他某种程度上成了我的非正式导师，为我在哈佛的正规研究生教育提供了一种替代性的教育。他经营着一个小组，每周在这个丹居住的房子里聚会一次。所以这些都是非常早期的影响，在塑造我的职业生涯中起到了至关重要的作用。
In his classes at Harvard, Richie's professors were teaching him about the science of psychology, about techniques being developed to objectively measure what happens inside the human mind. Much of this work was informed by a deep desire to help people suffering from mental disorders, to find cures for human anguish. Outside his classwork, Richie was learning
在哈佛的课堂上，理奇的教授们向他传授心理学科学，教授那些旨在客观测量人类思维内部发生的事情的技术。这项工作的很大一部分，源于帮助遭受精神障碍折磨的人、寻找人类痛苦治愈方法的深切渴望。在课堂作业之外，理奇正在每周的冥想练习中学习着
an entirely different education in his weekly meditation sessions. Another member of this group was John Kabatzin, who would go on to become one of the foremost practitioners of mindfulness training in medicine. Richie soon began his own daily meditation practice. Even at this early stage, he was starting to see the same connection that the Beatles had preached between changing your mind and changing the world. So here was Dan, who is a graduate student in Harvard, John, who had just finished his PhD at MIT. These are really high-powered academic institutions,
一种完全不同的教育。这个小组的另一位成员是乔恩·卡巴金（John Kabat-Zinn），他后来成为医学界正念训练的最杰出实践者之一。理奇很快开始了自己日常的冥想练习。即使在早期阶段，他也开始看到披头士所宣扬的改变你的思维与改变世界之间的那种联系。所以这里有丹，他是哈佛的研究生，还有乔恩，他刚刚在麻省理工学院获得博士学位。这些都是极具影响力的学术机构，
and they were kind, warm-hearted people. They exemplified the qualities that I was really looking for. And they were the kind of people that were infectious to be around. I really wanted to spend more time with them and learn what their secret sauce was. You know, that's when I discovered why, with Dan, I knew that he had a practice of meditation. And this was why I was drawn to it, because I had the intuition that their practice of meditation was somehow connected with them being such wonderful people. So warm-hearted. And I knew that that was important, not just for me, but for the world.
而他们是善良、热心肠的人。他们体现了我真正寻找的那些特质。他们是那种与之相处极具感染力的人。我真的很想花更多时间与他们在一起，了解他们的秘诀是什么。你知道，就在那时我发现，为什么对于丹，我知道他有冥想的习惯。这也是我被它吸引的原因，因为我有种直觉，他们冥想的习惯在某种程度上与他们成为如此美好的人息息相关。如此热心肠。我知道这不仅对我重要，对世界也很重要。
Once Richie tasted meditation, he wanted more. So two years later, in 1974, he decided to go on a meditation retreat in India. His girlfriend Susan joined him. I was 22 years old at the time. I had no idea what I was getting myself into. And it was really, you know, a hard-nosed kind of meditation boot camp. It was in a Himalayan hill station called Daohaazi,
一旦理奇品尝到了冥想的滋味，他就想要更多。因此两年后，即1974年，他决定去印度参加一个冥想静修营。他的女友苏珊（Susan）也加入了他的行列。我当时22岁。我根本不知道自己即将面对的是什么。这真的是一个毫不留情、硬核的冥想训练营。它位于喜马拉雅山的一个叫作道哈齐（Daohaazi）的山地度假胜地，
which is not far from where the Dalai Lama lives in Darmsala. The men were all staying in one area, the women in another area. We were staying intense. We had no running water. We had to get a pale of water each morning. We brought it to this fire pit and he did it up
距离达赖喇嘛在达兰萨拉的住所不远。男士们都住在同一个区域，女士们住在另一个区域。我们住在帐篷里。我们没有自来水。每天早上我们都得提一桶水。我们把水带到这个火坑旁，他把水烧热，
for our hot water for the day. And it was, we were meditating about 16 hours a day. We typically meditated till midnight and you know, around midnight and then the bell would ring to get us up at 4 or 30 in the morning. Then we'd go back. Yeah. The first day, Richie was walking up at 4 or 30
作为我们一天的热水。我们在那里每天冥想大约16个小时。我们通常冥想直到午夜，在午夜左右，然后钟声会响起，叫我们在清晨4点半起床。然后我们回去。是的。第一天，理奇在清晨4点半被
in the morning by the bell. He joined the other meditators and sat cross-legged in a half-loaded position. Richie attempted to focus on his breath. After some time, he felt a twinge of pain in his right knee. Then, the pain spread to his lower back. He tried to recast his attention to his breathing, but the pain was too much. By the end of the day, he thought, I can't believe I have nine more days of this.
钟声唤醒。他加入了其他冥想者的行列，盘腿坐在半莲花的姿势上。理奇试图专注于呼吸。过了一会儿，他感到右膝一阵刺痛。接着，疼痛蔓延到他的下背部。他试图将注意力重新投回呼吸上，但疼痛太剧烈了。到了一天结束时，他想：我简直不敢相信我还有九天要过这种日子。
That was really tough and gave me my first taste of intensive meditation. There was a lot of physical pain involved and it was very intense. And was there a part of you that sort of said, you know, four hours into it on the first day, this is not for me, I need to bail? Well, it's interesting that you bring that up. The teacher, by the way, was a very, very famous Buddhist meditation teacher by the name of Goenka. And each night he gives a talk.
那真的非常艰难，让我第一次尝到了高强度冥想的滋味。其中涉及大量的身体疼痛，而且非常强烈。有没有那么一刻，比如第一天开始四小时后，你心里会冒出这样的念头：这不适合我，我得逃跑？嗯，你提到这个很有意思。顺便说一句，那位老师是一位非常非常著名的佛教冥想老师，名叫葛印卡（Goenka）。他每天晚上都会做一个演讲。
And on the third day, he said, many of you probably are wanting to leave because the pain is unbearable, your mind is going crazy and you think that this is just not the right thing for you. And I was so invested by that point in meditation that I was going to just power through this no matter what. But Richie's girlfriend, Susan, had reached a different conclusion. She was in the middle of writing me a letter on the third day where she was just telling me in the letter some practical details that she's leaving. She's gonna stay in town. She'll meet me after the retreat is over,
到了第三天，他说：你们中的许多人可能想离开，因为疼痛让人难以忍受，你们的脑子快疯了，你们觉得这根本不适合你们。而我当时对冥想投入太深了，无论如何我都要咬牙挺过去。但理奇的女友苏珊却得出了不同的结论。第三天她正在给我写一封信，在信中她只是告诉我一些实际的细节，说她要离开。她打算留在镇上。等静修结束后她会和我汇合，
but this is not for her. And she was gonna give me the letter later that night and was gonna leave the next morning. And Goenka said at this talk, he said, for those of you thinking of leaving, I ask one thing, please stay another 24 hours. And if at that time you want to leave, you have my blessings, please leave. But I want you to make a commitment to stay one more day.
但这不适合她。她打算那天晚些时候把信交给我，并准备第二天早上离开。葛印卡在演讲中说道：对于那些想要离开的人，我只有一个要求，请再坚持24小时。如果到那时你仍然想离开，我祝福你，请离开。但我希望你作出承诺，再多待一天。
So Susan heard this and she honored that request and by the fourth day, everything changed. The next day, the teacher Goenka instructed the meditators to scan their body from head to toe and back again, from their toes up to their head, all the while paying close attention to what they felt. For Ritchie and Susan, it was a breakthrough. One of the important insights from this kind of practice is you begin to not avoid the pain, but you really look directly at the pain. And you begin to see that what the pain is comprised of is not homogeneous, but actually is quite differentiated. And so, you know, I remember very distinctly having the experience this first time of having the pain be completely transformed where I
于是苏珊听了这话，她遵守了这个请求，到了第四天，一切都变了。第二天，老师葛印卡指导冥想者从头到脚、再从头到脚地扫描自己的身体，从脚趾到头部，同时密切关注自己的感受。对理奇和苏珊来说，这是一个突破。这种练习的重要见解之一，就是你开始不再回避痛苦，而是真正直面痛苦。你开始发现，痛苦的组成并不是同质的，实际上有相当大的差异。所以，我非常清楚地记得第一次有这样的体验：痛苦发生了完全的转变，我
was experiencing it as tingling, as heat, as different kinds of sensations. And when you really penetrate it, you can see all of these varied qualities. And it's not just one thing. You know, we label it as pain, but that's a label. And that the actual experience is far more granular and differentiated. You know, the pain was completely transformed.
将它体验为刺痛、热感、以及各种不同的感觉。当你真正深入其中时，你能看到所有这些丰富多样的品质。它不只是一单一的东西。我们把它贴上“痛苦”的标签，但这只是一个标签。实际的体验要颗粒化、差异化得多。你知道，痛苦彻底转化了。
The positive qualities of this kind of practice became robust and apparent. And we just don't appreciate, we don't look, we're not aware of those kind of granular details typically, but we can be with the right kind of training and mindset. So, what were the positive things that you experienced, Richie? I mean, so you've described sort of how you're able to look at the pain and realize the pain is not one thing but many things. But when you sort of say you had this feeling that the benefits were apparent on the fourth day to you and to Susan, what were those benefits that you were seeing in your own mind?
这种练习的积极品质变得强韧而明显。通常情况下，我们并不懂得欣赏，不去观察，也没有意识到那些细微的细节，但在适当的训练和心态下，我们可以做到。理奇，你都体验到了哪些积极的方面呢？我的意思是，你已经描述了自己如何能够正视痛苦，并意识到痛苦不是单一事物而是许多事物。但是，当你提到在第四天你和苏珊都感觉到这种益处显现时，你们在自己的脑海中究竟看到了什么益处？
I would describe it as a kind of calm clarity, where the mind really settles and is very, very clear and very awake. Just taking everything in and really being calm and having this sense of peacefulness and also a kind of contentment where there was almost a sense that anything can come down the pike now and it's going to be okay. You write in your book, Alter Trades, we did not have to be controlled by the mind with the random associations, sudden fears and angersars and all the rest, we could take back the helm. And so there was some element of this that was very much about saying, you could actually be the master of the ship in some ways, the captain of the ship, and actually not just be essentially a passenger that your mind was taking where it wanted to go.
我会把它描述为一种平静的清晰感，大脑真正沉静下来，变得非常非常清晰和清醒。把一切都吸收进去，真正保持平静，拥有这种平和感，以及一种满足感。甚至几乎有一种感觉：现在不管有什么麻烦事袭来，一切都会没事的。你在书中写道：我们不必被那些充满随机联想、突如其来的恐惧和愤怒以及其他种种杂念的大脑所控制，我们可以夺回舵盘。所以这里有某种成分，非常关于这样一种说法：在某种程度上，你实际上可以成为这艘船的主人、船长，而不仅仅基本上是一个任由大脑带去任何地方的乘客。
The invitation in this work is that we can become the master of our own mind and we can intentionally direct our mind. And when we do the capabilities that are unleashed are really quite extraordinary, and every human being has this capacity. capacity. Tell me, you returned from India with this feeling of having, sort of almost on a high. What was it like to come back to Harvard, come back to graduate school? What was that like, the juxtaposition of what you were seeing, feeling and experiencing in your meditation practice and what you were learning about hearing about and being taught in your classes.
这项工作带来的邀请是，我们可以成为自己大脑的主人，我们可以刻意引导自己的大脑。当我们这样做时，被释放的能力真的是非同寻常的，而每个人都具备这种能力。告诉我，你带着这种仿佛处于某种亢奋状态的感觉从印度回来。回到哈佛，回到研究生院，那是什么感觉？你在冥想练习中所看到、感受到和体验到的，与你在课堂上学习、听说和被教导的产生了一种并置，那是什么感觉？
It was tough in many ways. One is that, you know, when you go on one of the kind of meditation retreat that I went on where you're doing this intensive practice, you're in complete silence, in completely sequestered. It's a little jarring to go back into the world. You know, the first few days, the sense of calm is mostly preserved. But then after a few days,
在很多方面这都很艰难。首先，当你参加我所经历的那种高强度冥想静修时，你进行这种高强度的练习，完全处于禁言状态，完全被隔离。再回到现实世界中会让人觉得有点格格不入。你知道，最初的几天，那种平静感大体上还能保持。但几天之后，
it honestly quickly wore off. It was a very difficult lesson in how fragile this is and what it takes for these qualities to really endure and that 10 days of sitting for 16 hours a day although to some people it may sound like a lot really to change the course of our mind you need a lot more. So that was the first thing. The second thing is that as a graduate student, I was learning a lot about psychopathology, psychiatric illness, and we were being taught to look at people and try to figure out what's
老实说，这种感觉很快就消退了。这是一次非常艰难的教训：这东西是多么脆弱，要让这些特质真正持久需要付出什么，以及虽然对某些人来说，坐着连续10天、每天16小时听起来很多，但要真正改变我们大脑的航向，你需要更多。所以这是第一件事。第二件事是，作为一名研究生，我正在学习很多关于精神病理学、精神疾病的知识，我们被教导去审视人们，并试图找出他们身上
wrong with them. And the path of meditation and the contemplative traditions in which I was beginning to learn a little bit about really had a very different orientation to look at people and to try to figure out what's right about them. And so there was this really difficult juxtaposition between the orientation that I was beginning to glean from these contemplative traditions and modern psychology, which for the most part was really focused on the negative qualities of our experience and our behavior. To Ritchie, it seemed like his teachers at Harvard were missing out on something important. During meditation, he could feel his own mind becoming clear.
出了什么问题。而我开始略有领悟的冥想之路以及那些传统，对审视人们和试图找出他们身上正确的东西有着截然不同的导向。因此，我从这些传统中开始汲取的导向，与现代心理学之间存在着一种非常困难的并置；现代心理学在很大程度上确实聚焦于我们体验和行为中的消极特质。在理奇看来，他在哈佛的教授们似乎忽略了一些重要的东西。在冥想期间，他能感觉到自己的大脑变得清澈。
He paid better attention to his surroundings. He felt less anxious, more compassion. Psychologists and neuroscientists were studying the mind in order to alleviate the suffering of people with emotional disorders. So why were the ignoring techniques developed in contemplative traditions that also promised an antidote to misery? I came back with this incredible conviction that meditation was relevant to Western psychology and Western science. And we really needed to bring this into
他能更好地关注周遭环境。他感到不那么焦虑，更有同情心。心理学家和神经科学家研究大脑是为了减轻情绪障碍患者的痛苦。那么，为什么他们要忽视那些在冥想传统中发展出来的、同样承诺能作为痛苦解药的技术呢？我带着一种难以置信的信念回来了：冥想与西方心理学和西方科学息息相关。我们真的需要把这一点带入
our science. And I still remember the visceral feeling I had when I encountered for the first time this passage in William James Great 2 volume tomb that was written in 1890. The principles of psychology has a whole chapter on attention. And he said in that chapter, the faculty of voluntarily bringing back a wandering attention over and over again is the very root of judgment, character, and will. And that to me was just incredible and was an invitation because what I was learning through meditation was at least in part how we can educate our attention. How did your professors, your colleagues, the other people in the department, how did they process what you were doing? I mean, some people must have thought you'd just gone off the deep end here.
我们的科学中。我依然记得当我第一次遇到威廉·詹姆斯（William James）1890年撰写的伟大的两卷本巨著中的这段话时，内心产生的直观感受。《心理学原理》中有一整章都在讲注意力。他在那一章里说：自愿将游离的注意力一遍又一遍地拉回来的能力，正是判断力、性格和意志的根基。对我来说，这简直不可思议，这是一个邀请，因为我通过冥想正在学习的，至少部分是如何训练我们的注意力。你的教授、你的同事、系里的其他人，是如何看待你所做的事情的？我的意思是，有些人一定觉得你在这里已经彻底走火入魔了。
what you were doing. I mean, some people must have thought you'd just gone off the deep end here. They did. Some people did and I won't name names, but there was one professor in particular at Harvard. I will never forget this in a class on psychopathology where, you know, I had just come back from India and was adopting the same dress that Dan Goldman had when I met him the first time. And he was staring at me and he said, you know, one of the easy indications of psychopathology is the way people dress. And first of all, it was a ridiculous statement. It was clear that I was very much being singled out. I turned red, you know,
你所做的事情。我的意思是，有些人的确一定觉得你在这里已经彻底走火入魔了。他们的确这么想。有些人确实这么想，我不点名了，但哈佛有一位教授特别让我难忘。我永远不会忘记在一堂精神病理学课上，你知道，我刚从印度回来，穿着和我在初次见面时丹·戈尔曼一样的服装。他盯着我说：你知道，精神病理学的一个简单表征就是人们的穿着方式。首先，这是一个荒谬的说法。很明显，我被特别针对了。我的脸涨得通红，你知道，
I, you know, those were days when I was more volatile. And so I didn't say anything in class, but after class, you know, I didn't mince words in saying what I thought of this professor. of this professor, it was hard. And fortunately, most of the my classmates were also rooting for me and appreciated what I was trying to do. In fact, I was celebrating the opportunity to bring rigor to the study of these qualities. And so my fellow classmates appreciated that. When the professor said this, I mean this professor doesn't sound like a particularly
那是我脾气更暴躁的日子。所以我当时在课上什么也没说，但下课后，对于我对这位教授的看法，我没有说客套话。
nice person and certainly wasn't a very kind comment, but where do you think this was coming from? So there's clearly the tension between the fact that what you were learning in graduate school was fundamentally focused on psychopathology, what you had learned in your meditation practice was about potential, the ways in which our minds could be better than they are. So it wasn't so much about fixing something that was wrong. It was about reaching a higher mountain, if you will. But besides that distinction, can you talk a moment about the suspicion or the hesitation that justified or unjustified
对于这位教授的看法，那段日子很艰难。幸运的是，我的大多数同班同学也都在支持我，并赞赏我试图做的事。事实上，我当时在庆祝能有机会为这些特质的研究带来严谨性。所以我的同班同学对此表示赞赏。当教授说出这话时，我的意思是这位教授听起来并不是一个特别
was present at Harvard about the work that you were doing itself, the whole enterprise of basically studying the mind from the inside out rather than from the outside in? Yeah, that's a great question. I think that there are a few things that we're driving this. One is a suspicion that this might lead to bad science. You know, everyone knew that I went to India, that I went on a meditation retreat, that I was doing this personally. And there was this sense that somehow this was tainting my objectivity, and I was going to become a religious zealot as a consequence. So I think that there was some concern about that.
好的人，当然也不是一个很友善的评论，但你认为这源于哪里呢？所以很明显，存在这样一种紧张关系：你在研究生院学到的东西从根本上聚焦于精神病理学，而你在冥想练习中学到的是关于潜能，关于我们的思维可以变得比现在更好的方式。所以它与其说是关于修复出了问题的东西，不如说是关于攀登更高山峰的追求。但除了这种区别之外，你能谈谈当时在哈佛，对你所做的工作本身、对从内到外而不是从外部来研究思维的整个事业，那种无论是否合理的怀疑或犹豫是从何而来的吗？嗯，这是一个很好的问题。我认为有几件事情在推动这一点。首先是怀疑这可能会导致糟糕的科学。你知道，大家都知道我去了印度，我去参加了冥想静修营，我是在个人层面这样做的。并且有一种感觉，这在某种程度上玷污了我的客观性，因此我会变成一个宗教狂热分子。所以我认为确实存在一些对此的担忧。
There are a few papers at the time on meditation research that were frankly pretty bad. And so, I think that there was a sense that this was kind of boondoggle area that just was replete with bad science and not something that a Harvard graduate student should be involved with. Yeah, going back to that sleep study you did when you were a kid, there's the experience that we all have when we are dreaming. It feels rich, it feels subjective.
当时关于冥想研究的几篇论文坦白说相当糟糕。因此，我认为有一种看法认为这是一个毫无意义的领域，充满了糟糕的科学，不是一个哈佛研究生应该参与的事情。是的，回到你小时候做的那项睡眠研究，我们在做梦时都有这样的体验。它感觉很丰富，感觉很主观。
I remember at least how it felt like when I was dreaming last night. And then someone comes in and says, I can put EEGs on your skull and on your eyelids. And I can measure something that is in some ways an artifact of what it is that you're experiencing. And they're both ways of perceiving something that's happening inside our brains,
我至少还记得昨晚做梦时的感觉。然后有人走进来，说我可以在你的头骨和眼睑上贴上脑电图（EEG）电极。我可以测量出在某种程度上是你正在经历的事物的某种表征。它们都是感知大脑内部发生事情的方法，
but they are very, very different approaches. They're approaching the question from entirely different perspectives. And so it's perhaps not entirely surprising, Richie, that people from each of these paths will look at the people on the other path with some suspicion. Yeah, I think that's very true.
但它们是非常非常不同的方法。它们从完全不同的视角来探讨这个问题。因此，理奇，来自这两条路径的人以某种怀疑的眼光看待另一条路径上的人，也许并非完全出人意料。是的，我认为这非常真实。
And there is this great neurobiologist who prematurely passed away from liver disease in 2001. His name is Francisco Verella. One of the hallmarks of his career was to talk about the importance of bringing first person and third person methods together. First person are the reports of our own experience. Third person is measurements that a like a scientist can do where we record brain activity or eye movements on another person and being able to bring these two very different modes of knowing together and look for points of convergence is really exciting because of that promise because it was bringing these two together. When we come back, Richie tries to bring the two paths together. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
有这样一位伟大的神经生物学家，在2001年因肝病过早离世。他的名字叫弗朗西斯科·瓦雷拉（Francisco Varela）。他职业生涯的一个标志性特点，就是谈论将第一人称和第三人称方法结合起来的重要性。第一人称是我们对自己体验的报告。第三人称是像科学家那样可以进行的测量，我们在另一个人身上记录脑电活动或眼球运动。能够将这两种截然不同的认知模式结合起来，并寻找交汇点，由于这种承诺，因为把这两者结合在了一起，所以真的令人兴奋。稍后回来，理奇将尝试把这两条路径结合起来。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When he was a graduate student, Ritchie Davidson was fascinated by two different languages that tried to describe the mind. One reported from inside the mind. The other peered into the mind from the outside. As Richie became an academic, older faculty members warned him, stay away from explorations into meditation and mindfulness. They were bound to be unscientific, unsound. I had this fervent aspiration to do research on meditation and I was told in no uncertain terms Richie if you want a successful career in science this is a terrible way for you to begin. Richie followed the advice he dove into the field of affective
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当理奇·戴维森还是个研究生时，他被试图描述大脑的两种不同语言深深吸引。一种语言从思维内部进行报告。另一种语言从外部窥视思维。随着理奇成为一名学者，年长的教职员工警告他：远离对冥想和正念的探索。它们注定是不科学的、不可靠的。我当时有着炽热的愿望，想要对冥想进行研究，但有人斩钉截铁地告诉我：理奇，如果你想在科学界获得成功的职业生涯，这是一个糟糕的开端。理奇听从了建议，他一头扎进了情感
neuroscience how the brain processes emotions. He spoke almost exclusively in the language of mainstream science and wrote papers that examined the mind from the outside in. He used tools like EEG tests to measure the electrical activity of the brain. Richie's career flourished. He published his work in prestigious journals, received awards, and got a tenured position at the University of Wisconsin. All the while, he maintained his daily meditation practice and attended more retreats. In 1992, an opportunity arose to do what he had been trying to do since he was a graduate student.
神经科学领域，研究大脑如何处理情绪。他几乎完全使用主流科学的语言进行交流，并撰写了从外到内审视思维的论文。他使用诸如脑电图（EEG）测试之类的工具来测量大脑的电活动。理奇的职业生涯蒸蒸日上。他在知名期刊上发表了研究成果，获得了奖项，并在威斯康星大学获得了终身教职。与此同时，他一直保持着每天冥想的习惯，并参加了更多的静修营。1992年，一个机会出现了，让他能够去做他自研究生以来一直努力想做的事情。
Build a bridge between these two languages that describe the mind. Become a translator between the outside and approach and the inside out approach. Besides, this opportunity came with a very special invitation to meet the ultimate meditation teacher, the Dalai Lama. He was interested in encouraging serious neuroscientific research on meditation, particularly the practices from his tradition. Through some common acquaintances, he heard about me. He knew that I was a serious neuroscientist and had interest in meditation. And he invited me along with two other scientists to meet with him at his residence in Darmsala with the
在描述心灵的这两种语言之间架起一座桥梁。成为外在切入法与内在切入法之间的翻译者。此外，这个机会还伴随着一个非常特别的邀请，去见终极冥想导师——达赖喇嘛。他有兴趣鼓励对冥想进行严格的神经科学研究，特别是他传统中的修行。通过一些共同的熟人，他听说了我。他知道我是一位严肃的神经科学家，并且对冥想感兴趣。他邀请我和另外两位科学家一起去他在达兰萨拉的住所会面，其
explicit purpose of beginning to investigate practitioners who have spent years meditating, who are living in the mountains around Armçala. And so the way this visit was constructed is we were going to meet with him first and then we We slept about 5,000 pounds of equipment with us. We looked like this strange melding of a bunch of geeks and like a traveling rock band because we had these huge cases. We brought all this equipment and there we were. And so I was the leader of this group. And this was the first time I was meeting the Dalai Lama. So we were meeting him at his residence.
明确目的是开始调查那些在达兰萨拉周围大山里生活、花费多年时间进行冥想的修行者。这次访问的安排是，我们先去见他，然后我们随身带了大约5000磅的设备。我们看起来就像一群极客和一支巡回乐队的奇怪结合体，因为我们有这些巨大的箱子。我们带了所有这些设备，我们就这样去了。我是这个团队的领队。这也是我第一次见到达赖喇嘛。所以我们在他的住所与他会面。
I was the spokesperson. And so we were sitting there waiting. And I had what was the closest I've ever come to having a full blown panic attack. to having a full blown panic attack. I was so anxious and my heart was palpitating and I could not envision what my first words would be and I was beginning to be flooded with self-doubt. Who am I to waste the time of the Dalai Lama?
我是发言人。我们坐在那里等待。我当时经历了我有生以来最接近全面恐慌发作的状态。经历了全面恐慌发作。我太焦虑了，心跳加速，我无法想象我的第一句话会是什么，我开始被自我怀疑淹没。我是谁，竟然敢浪费达赖喇嘛的时间？
Why am I here? All of those thoughts. And then all of a sudden, someone comes in the room and said, please come with me, took us into the next room, and literally two seconds after that, the Dalai Lama walks in. And within maybe 10, 15 seconds, all of my anxiety was completely and totally dissipated. I mean, just radically eliminated. I'm convinced he saw my anxiety. He saw my anxiety. He saw my suffering and he behaved in a way
我为什么会在这里？所有这些想法。然后突然间，有人走进房间说，请跟我来，把我们带到隔壁房间，字面意思是在那之后的两秒钟，达赖喇嘛走了进来。在大概10到15秒内，我所有的焦虑完全彻底地消散了。我是说，简直是被彻底清除了。我确信他看到了我的焦虑。他看到了我的焦虑。他看到了我的痛苦，并且他的举动
that completely eliminated it. I don't exactly know what he did. He held me, he held my hand. He brought my head to his head. He touched me. I mean, he uses touch a lot. It is an expression of genuine compassion and love. It is enormously helpful. And I felt more comfortable
完全消除了它。我不太清楚他做了什么。他握着我，握着我的手。他把我的头贴向他的头。他触碰了我。我的意思是，他经常使用身体接触。这是真诚的同情和爱的表达。这极其有帮助。我感到比以往任何时候都
than I think I've ever felt in my life. And was just felt deeply secure and that this is where I needed to be. And you had the sense this was again not just somebody who happened to be a nice person, you had a sense that it was his practice, his meditation practice, his yours of practice that were bringing something out in him that touched you. Absolutely. I am absolutely convinced of that. He practices on average four to five hours every day. One of the things that he does is recites some texts from Shanti David, the great Indian saint, and I actually have this right on my desk here. I read it every day from Shanti Deva, the great Indian saint. And I actually have this right on my desk here. I read it every day, Shanti Deva says,
更加舒适。而且感到内心深处无比的安全，觉得这就是我应该在的地方。你会有这种感觉，这不仅仅是一个碰巧是个好人的人，你有一种感觉，是他的修行，他的冥想修行，他多年的修行，唤醒了他身上某种能触动你的东西。绝对的。我对此深信不疑。他平均每天修行四到五个小时。他做的事情之一就是背诵印度伟大圣者香提·提婆的一些文本，我实际上就把这个放在我这里的桌子上。我每天都读香提·提婆的话，我实际上就把这个放在我这里的桌子上。我每天都读，香提·提婆说，
for as long as space endures, and for as long as living beings remain, until then may I too abide to dispel the misery of the world. So you visit Tadalai Lama, you're moved by this visit, you also have 5,000 pounds of equipment that you've caught it from the United States to India. What happens do you start to study people on the strip? So each day we literally hiked up into the mountains. We took a car as far as we can take a car and then the road stops and then the rest of the way you need to go on foot. And we had a bunch of shurpers with us and they were carrying equipment on backpacks.
只要虚空还在，只要众生活着，愿我也能常住于此，以消除世间的痛苦。所以你拜访了达赖喇嘛，你被这次访问打动了，你还从美国带了5000磅的设备到印度。发生了什么，你开始研究这些人了吗？所以我们每天实际上都徒步上山。我们坐车能开多远就开多远，然后路就到了尽头，接下来的路就必须步行。我们带了一群夏尔巴人，他们用背包背着设备。
And we literally hiked up in certain cases quite a long time, two hours, three hours, to these huts and caves, where these long-term retreations are living in retreat for the remainder of their lives. Of course, we would never be able to find these people if we went on our own. We went with someone who was a representative
在某些情况下，我们确实徒步走了相当长的时间，两个小时，三个小时，到达这些简陋的小屋和山洞，这些长期闭关的人余生都在这里闭关修行。当然，如果我们自己去的话，永远也找不到这些人。我们和一个代表一起去
of the Dalai Lama and who obviously knew where these people resided. And over the course of this three weeks, we saw maybe about 12 of these very long term practitioners, some of whom have been in retreat for more than a decade. The response that we got from every one of them was this. That if we wanted to learn about meditation, they'd be happy to teach us. They'll be happy to spend the next couple of years teaching us if we wanted. And remember what year this was. This was in 1992. Most of these people with the exception of maybe two had actually never seen a laptop computer before. They were completely untudered in Western technology. And so what these people basically said to us is that they're happy to talk to us about meditation.
达赖喇嘛的代表，他显然知道这些人住在哪里。在接下来的三周里，我们大约见到了这12位长期修行者，其中一些人闭关已经超过十年。我们从他们每个人那里得到的回答都是这样的。如果我们想了解冥想，他们很乐意教我们。如果我们愿意，他们很乐意花接下来的几年时间教我们。请记住这是哪一年。这是在1992年。除了两个人之外，这些人大多数以前甚至从未见过笔记本电脑。他们对西方技术完全一无所知。所以这些人对我们说的基本上是，他们很高兴跟我们谈论冥想。
They're happy to teach us about meditation, but they don't want to participate in the research. They had this view that somehow if we put electrodes on their head, it's going to put something into their into their head. And we explain to them that the electrodes don't transmit electricity, they simply pick up electricity. Nevertheless, they were skeptical and they didn't want to participate. And so over the course of three weeks, literally zero of the practitioners agreed to allow us to put electrodes on their head.
他们很高兴教我们关于冥想的知识，但他们不想参与这项研究。他们有一种看法，觉得如果我们把电极放在他们的头上，就会把什么东西放进他们的脑子里。我们向他们解释说，电极不传输电，它们只是接收电。尽管如此，他们还是持怀疑态度，不想参与。因此，在三 weeks 的时间里，实际上没有任何一个修行者同意让我们把电极放在他们的头上。
It was very frustrating and challenging as total and complete bust. I mean, it's interesting that I just want to note the irony here for a second, which is it wasn't just the professors at Harvard, who was skeptical and suspicious of, you know, the ideas coming from the meditators. It was also the master meditators who are skeptical and suspicious of the Western scientists coming to study them. Exactly. Exactly.
这非常令人沮丧和具有挑战性，完全是一个彻底的失败。我的意思是，有趣的是，我只想在这里指出一个反讽，那就是，不仅哈佛的教授们对冥想者传达的想法持怀疑和不信任态度，那些大师级的冥想者也对前来研究他们的西方科学家持怀疑和不信任态度。完全正确。完全正确。
So I was really screwed from both ends. But the way you put it is absolutely right, and it's totally true. Richie had given himself a dauntingly ambitious goal, to become a translator between two ways of understanding the mind. That endeavor had failed and failed spectacularly. In part two of the story in our next episode, Richie discovers something very strange about the minds of master meditators. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick.
所以我两头受挫。但你这种说法绝对正确，而且完全属实。里奇给自己设定了一个极其宏伟的目标——成为理解心灵的两种方式之间的翻译者。那次尝试失败了，而且失败得相当壮观。在下一集故事的第二部分中，里奇发现了关于大师级冥想者心灵的一些非常奇怪的事情。“隐藏大脑”由“隐藏大脑”传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our own song heroes today are Heather Harris, Max Co., and Jenny Wynn. They walk with Richie and help to organize this interview. Between my hectic schedule and Richie's busy calendar, believe me, it took some doing. Thank you, Heather, Max, and Jenny. If you find Hidden Brain to be useful to you in your daily life, please consider joining our new podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. Hidden Brain Plus is where you'll find even more of the ideas and insights that you love. To subscribe, find Hidden Brain Plus in the Apple Podcasts app or go to apple.co slash hidden brain. That site again is apple.co slash I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏大脑”的执行编辑。我们今天的音频英雄是海瑟·哈里斯、马克斯·科和珍妮·温。他们与里奇同行并协助组织了这次采访。在我的繁忙日程和里奇的满满行程之间，相信我，这着实花了不少功夫。谢谢你们，海瑟、马克斯和珍妮。如果您发现“隐藏大脑”对您的日常生活有所帮助，请考虑加入我们的全新播客订阅服务——“隐藏大脑+”。在“隐藏大脑+”中，您将找到更多您喜爱的观点和见解。要订阅，请在苹果播客应用中搜索“隐藏大脑+”，或访问 apple.co/hiddenbrain。再次说明，网址是 apple.co/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。